can america remain a global leader given
the path that we're on uh you have to be
financially strong history has shown
that when the coffers are empty and
there's a need to spend more money
um that then there's always the creation
the printing of money which the values
it and that's a problem the second issue
is how we are with each other
there's a real tendency when you have
financial problems um
and polarity to have increased
uh populism of the left and increased
populism of the right
and that greater and greater polarity
when conditions are problematic um
can produce periods of disorder periods
of um
types of civil war
uh for example it's not inconceivable
that neither side would give up losing
would accept losing in the next
presidential election in which case that
would threaten the system and so how
people are with each other whether they
are working cohesively to common goals
and productively is very important
and then those two factors most
importantly
affect the strength of the country and
of course
the strength of the country relative to
other countries such as china is of
paramount
importance